el sur de Perú donde comenzó el
estallido social hace casi dos meses las
desigualdades sociales la pobreza el
saqueo y el histórico abandono Estatal
sacó a las calles a miles de peruanos
tras la destitución del expresidente
Pedro Castillo luego de un intento
fallido de golpe de estado no siempre
nos cuesta el sudor y el trabajo
sacrificio porque no hay ni del Estado
miró esa institución no hay apoyo
muchos se veían reflejados en ese
profesor de la ruralidad peruana que
prometía sacar a las regiones indígenas
y campesinas del olvido Sí nosotros
sentimos que desprecian hay un
centralismo fuerte como en la Colonia
Lima sigue siendo la capital política
económica y administrativa del país
Entonces nosotros nos sentimos
indignados frente a eso el estallido
social todavía se mantiene en estos
territorios muchos manifestantes
llegaron incluso a la capital lima para
exigir la renuncia de la presidenta
dinable el adelanto de elecciones el
cierre del Congreso y tras la brutal
respuesta de las fuerzas del orden
justicia para las casi 60 víctimas
mortales durante las protestas la
mayoría jóvenes indígenas y Campesinos
de la ruralidad jamás invirtieron en los
andes tomando en cuenta que los Andes
que todas las Sierra es la que mantiene
a la capital del Perú cómo es posible
que nosotros siendo Dueños del gas no
tengamos gas nosotros siendo dueños de
todas las minerías y teniendo los
famosos Canon minero no tengamos buenos
colegios buenos hospitales las últimas
semanas El Poder y las élites de Lima
calificaron a los manifestantes de
terroristas el jueves la ministra de
exteriores Ana Cecilia gervasi dijo al
New York Times que no hay ninguna
evidencia de que las protestas
estuvieran impulsadas por grupos
delincuenciales Pese a que días antes la
misma boluarte hizo tales señalamientos